[Music]
Blake first things first I gotta get an
update on Gwen's ear how is she doing uh
she's getting bad you know I think
something like that's just slow I mean
pop your blow your eardrum out I mean
that's like I don't even know how that
happens about my high heels either but
she says she can hear now she'll be our
I think the cabin pressure in her
airplane she had a head cold and then
once they got up to a certain altitude
they say not to fly if you have a head
cold but we all do but that's the thing
I guess that could happen so well
wishing her a speedy recovery um she'll
be she's singing tomorrow she's she's
doing good yeah she's back at it yeah oh
yeah she's tough well Blake I've got to
ask both of you actually about are you
working on new music your album is
almost a year old I heard you saying
that you are getting back in the studio
so what's the latest for both of you my
next body of work is already in the
works oh I'm I'm excited I can't wait
for you to hear new music and so that's
one of the reasons why I'm not gonna be
able to come back for next season but um
but I love writing you can always come
back at it and do something new you know
yeah unless you're Blake and then do the
same old crap right so but I like your
same old crap but I was cool with me
well what about writing with Gwen again
recording with Glen man I hope so uh I
mean that last album I made I said that
was gonna be my life this next album uh
that I'm making is probably gonna be my
last album oh it's not Sam and so I
really got to decide what I want to do
it's probably gonna be my last record I
know why would you add a nice record and
just allowing my last season of this
show I'll do entertainment anymore kids
I'm sorry I don't believe either of
those things how do you not do an
entertainment though I really I could
like I could see you just out you know
in them living off the land like just
kind of you know really getting up early
and weeding and the whole win or
whatever Whedon you said you're gonna be
Whedon that's what you said Weidman
hoenn Whedon already been diggin poen
means something different in Oklahoma
that's when you go to our
[Music]
you